legendary music executive that would be
the one and only clive davis he is
signed as you know some of the biggest
names in the business including barry
manilow patty smith billy joel earthwind
and fire the list is very long
davis celebrated his 90th birthday
earlier this month it was a star-studded
event including an impromptu performance
by one artist that he signed the lovely
alicia keys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we talked with clive davis about the
birthday milestone and launching the
careers of some of music's biggest
superstars
i'll tick off the names and you just
give one sentence janice joplin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
electrifying hypnotic a white soul
system like no other aretha franklin
[Music]
one of the
most nurturing satisfying
relationships that i've had from music
was with the rebound and
bruce springsteen
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no one like bruce bernstein he
not only is a brilliant
poet warrior
to me he became the best rock performer
ever nowadays a lot of artists become
very famous very quickly on social media
because their music goes viral instantly
do you think it's harder or easier to
find talent today
it would be
harder
because right now there's no bob dylan
there's no bruce springsteen right now
there's no aretha franklin and there
might not have been clive davis hit
maker either he was never drawn to music
in fact he began his career as a lawyer
i was plucked out of a law firm to
become chief lawyer
for columbia records three years out of
oscar law school
i did that for five years
and then made head of columbia records
okay with no training in music
did you think you'd be good at this
i never thought i would have a musical
ear i never thought i'd have a natural
gift no way do you play an instrument no
no
okay how did you learn to be good and as
good as you are at this job you don't
learn to be good you don't you just
do what came natural i'm fascinated by
your ear
let me feel it make sure it's a real ear
wait a second
it does feel like a real ear but this is
the thing that's fascinating about your
ears because they call you the man with
the golden ears you're a master at all
of the genres because of those golden
ears
it's a gift that i found i had that i
never knew i had whether it's an artist
or a song
[Music]
he is an inspiration to everybody in the
music business and most of all to me on
the red carpet at his recent 90th
birthday party the artists say the
secret to davis's success is mutual
respect he's completely artist friendly
and the artist always comes first there
are so many accolades for you that night
but i love wyclef john who said on the
red carpet you see how all these rappers
be trying to act like they're gangsters
clive davis is the real gangster what do
you think he meant by that
i think he meant
that i have a very special connection
with artists with music
i certainly know i had it with him
[Music]
heard you describe her as close to you
as a daughter were you aware of the
struggles that she was having at the
time that she was having them
i probably was not aware i never saw it
she was always on top of her game when
we were playing but when i did see it
i did confront her she listened but she
didn't agree but then
a few years later she did make
a valiant effort
you know to
rehab 48 hours before she passed away we
spent the afternoon in l.a she was
so looking forward to life so looking
forward to making another album
that to this day it
you know shakes me up to realize the
power of drugs
how do you know what a hit single sounds
like
i couldn't explain it to you if i tried
really the answer is i do know
i do know when i hear a hit song
and so simon and carl book will never
forget that
when they played me bridge over troubled
water i said that has got to be the
first single
[Music]
it felt
it was so classic
and it still to this day is my
favorite song so let's wrap up with this
you know uh you're known for your golden
ear you're known for your nose for
talent
let's end with you pick a song and we'll
sing us out of this interview can you
sing clive no yes you can oh i can yes
you can yes i can
i wish i could you got to know what you
can do and you got to know what you can
do
so that all right well well can you just
pick a song just for you and i that we
could just end this interview with
and we'll sing it together because i
can't bridge over
troubled water
i will lay me down
like a bridge over trouble trouble it's
the greatest song and the most touching
meaningful
beautiful song that you and i have just
i will lay partly ruined yes
clive we are both very bad high five on
that
oh gosh the crew is so bad
keep the audience there howling like
dogs in here
listen i adore clive davis that was a
lot of fun you know he's 90 years old he
has no plans to slow down he says once a
song hits the top 20 he listens to it
just to make sure that he still can hear
what other people hear that it's a hit
and kenny g had the best story i think
on the red carpet because he said he has
a one of the best selling uh christmas
albums clive wanted no vocals but it
went to a hit and clive said if you put
vocals it was sold 100 million more
clive davis legend gangster gail a
gangster yeah include that singing i saw
clive turned down his hearing aid